president trump and his allies have lost
59 lawsuits alleging election fraud
however that hasn't stopped the
president or his fans from propagating
totally insane conspiracy theories
involving dead communist leaders and the
voting machines who
loved them unfortunately for president
trump this information is
false but you can imagine that
perpetrating the falsity of these
facts is really bad for business if you
are dominion or smartmatic some of the
manufacturers of some of these voting
machines
but could this be one of the rare cases
of honest-to-goodness defamation
well maybe and smart mannequin dominion
are filing lawsuits worth
billions of dollars but before we
continue there are obviously some wild
accusations being made
and there are billions of dollars at
stake and we here at legal eagle take
these
accusations very seriously in fact
smeagle at the legal eagle legal
department is forcing me to display this
disclaimer
please read it carefully by continuing
with this video you agree to be bound by
the terms and conditions
[Music]
sponsored by ting mobile hey legal
eagles it's time to think like a
defamation lawyer legal eagle has
covered defamation lawsuits many times
remember the good old days of
devin nunes versus devin nunez's cow
tulsi gabbard versus hillary clinton
and donald trump versus the new york
times well all of those cases got
dismissed because
they were just not good claims it's
really hard to make a
viable defamation claim however when the
leader of the western world makes claims
about voting systems calling them rigged
he empowers other people to repeat those
claims even when they're patently false
that's why the pro-trump media ecosystem
is totally awash in conspiracy theories
involving dominion and smartmatic
two of the companies which provided
election support in 2020.
it was only a matter of time before
those companies and their employees
fought back and
one lawsuit has been filed several other
lawsuits have been threatened
and trump allied media is retracting
those claims like crazy so let's take a
look at the suits that dominion and
smartmatic have filed and threatened to
file against president trump and his
surrogates but before we dig into those
lawsuits
a word of warning it's very easy to get
caught up
in cheering people using the
institutions of government to stifle
speech that we don't agree with but the
first amendment exists
for a reason it protects speech that we
like and speech that we don't like and
in the past when
people have filed suit against the new
york times or when president trump filed
suit
against a tiny tv station in wisconsin
it was clear that these defamation suits
were bogus
because those plaintiffs would never be
able to meet their burden it's hard to
make a defamation claim
and for very good reason but just
because we think that what's being
stated is false
or we might think that the people who
are propagating these falsities are
let's say misinformed at best that
doesn't mean it should be any less hard
for
someone to be able to prove a defamation
claim against them it's my personal
opinion but i think that the first
amendment is uh
quite a good thing in our society and we
should be very very reluctant to cheer
on anyone
uh making a claim that could end up
stifling speech that we just don't agree
with
and additionally in another context or
even in this particular context this is
a corporation trying to stifle criticism
against that corporation
it just so happens that in this
particular context it seems like the
criticisms are all in bad faith and
are completely made up and false but
with that warning out of the way let's
talk about the lawsuits that have been
filed with regards to the dominion and
smartmatic voting machines the first
lawsuit that was filed was by an
employee of dominion which is a company
that makes voting machines in 2020
dominion partnered with more than 300
jurisdictions in the united states to
provide
various election support services the
plaintiff is eric
coomer he's the director of product
strategy and security for dominion
and if you haven't heard of dr coomer
it's probably because you aren't
spending enough time consuming pro-trump
media like newsmax oann
and your uncle's facebook page because
there he's practically a celebrity in
the aftermath of biden's victory
conspiracy theorists about dr coomber
spread like wildfire all over
conservative media this started with a
story told by
an entrepreneur and podcast host joseph
altman
who claims he eavesdropped on an antifa
conference call
where antifa activists discuss their
evil plans during this conference call
altman
says that someone who introduced himself
as eric from dominion
stated he would ensure the election went
to joe biden here's altman telling eric
mataxis that he infiltrated antifa
i had a group of people and we
infiltrated um
antifa then altman discovered that there
was a dominion employee on the line
allegedly you know this guy named eric
started talking and then somebody
asked uh who eric was
and they said eric's a dominion guy then
eric from dominion said he was going to
just you know
rig the entire election and i'm
paraphrasing this right so i didn't
write down word for word what he said
but uh eric responds don't worry about
the election trump's not going to win
i've made effing sure of that so he made
effing sure of that
uh effing means very very oldman offered
no explanation of how he allegedly
infiltrated the call nor does he have a
recording of it nevertheless
altman decided that the eric was
actually eric coomer he then decided
that this was proof that dr coomer
may have just rigged the election for
joe biden and within days the hashtags
eric coomer
exposed eric hoomer and arrest eric
humer were trending on social media and
of course president trump
published similar false statements on
twitter alleging that dominion had
interfered with the election
eric trump tweeted a photo of dr coomer
and allege that he rigged the election
the other defendants published altman's
false allegations about dr coomer and
altman appeared on youtube videos radio
programs and television shows the host
of these programs repeatedly false
allegations and for example michelle
malkin interviewed altman and started
tweeting his allegations as if they were
true quote
trump's campaign lawyers identified dr
coomer in a nationally televised press
conference where they described him as
quote a vicious vicious
man who is quote close to antifa and
falsely claimed that dr coomber
specifically says that they're going to
fix this election and that he quote
had the election rigged for mr biden so
seemingly in response to these
allegations dr kumar sued all of the
defendants for defamation and
intentional infliction of emotional
distress
he also sued them for civil conspiracy
alleging they coordinated with each
other to spread lies about dr kumar
himself
okay so those are the facts as alleged
in the lawsuit but before we dig
into this particular lawsuit let's
examine what you have to prove to
actually make a claim
for defamation now as you probably know
defamation is making a provably false
statement a fact about a person
or a company yes companies can be the
victim of defamation but what are the
elements what do you have to prove to
make a defamation claim
in court well first the content of the
communication has to be factual in
nature
and opinion is not defamation so if you
get on yelp and write a savage review of
popeye's chicken sandwich
this is an opinion it's not fact the
internet may ratio you for preferring
the chick-fil-a sandwich
but popeyes can't sue you for failing to
recognize the factual truth because
there is no factual truth to recognize
most opinion is protected
under first amendment free speech but on
the other hand if you write a bad review
because you say that your chicken
sandwich had a human finger in it
well that's not an opinion anymore
that's a verifiable provable fact
and if that's false it could give rise
to a claim for defamation which takes us
to the second element
the content of the communication must be
false someone can say something mean
that might cause harm to another
person's reputation just because you've
harmed someone's reputation doesn't mean
that you have committed defamation but
that reputation-harming statement
must in fact be true if it is true it
doesn't constitute defamation if it's
false
and you have impugned someone's
character it's possible that that might
give rise to a defamation claim that's
why we say that truth is an absolute
defense to defamation
it does get a little bit wonky because
truth is both an affirmative defense
something the defense can prove to
defeat a claim of defamation
but it's also an element that the
plaintiff has to prove they have to
prove that the
original communication was in fact false
but that takes us to the third element
which is that the content is made with
either negligence or
actual malice when a private person
brings a defamation claim they need to
only show
negligence by the party who published
the communication or statement in other
words that
the person was negligent in saying
something that was
in fact false but you probably know that
public figures must prove
an allegedly defamatory statement was
made with what's called actual malice
now actual malice has absolutely
nothing to do with maliciousness if you
take anything away from this video it is
that
actual malice is not about the
maliciousness with which someone repeats
something that's false actual malice is
just a legal term of art that means that
the person making the statement must
have known
that the statement was false or that the
person making the statement
made it with reckless disregard for that
truth in other words that's a pretty
high burden to show that someone
was either knowingly saying something
that was false or recklessly saying
something that was false thus if you are
a public figure or a celebrity a
politician
and often a private business you're
subjected to proven your defamation
claim by this higher standard of proof
called actual malice which takes us to
the fourth element which is that the
content could be defamation per se this
is also something that is
often misunderstood in most states there
is a
subset of communications that are
considered so harmful that damages to an
injured person's reputation
are assumed and the plaintiff doesn't
need to prove damages generally
if you make a claim for defamation you
have to prove damages
but uh for old old reasons in law
there are some categories that are just
assumed that a person's reputation is
damaged if you say it so for example
in new york there are four categories of
speech where it's defamation per se
statements that accuse someone of
committing a serious crime statements
that injure a person's business or
profession
statements that someone has a loathsome
disease and a statement that a person is
unchaste yes really unchastity
is one of the kinds of things that are
defamation per se if you are accused of
being unchaste
you don't have to actually prove your
damages in order to make
an actual claim for defamation and
regarding damages there's generally
three different kinds this goes for just
about any civil claim you can make but
it's relevant when it comes to damages
first there's special damages those are
generally economic things that the
plaintiff actually has suffered so in
the context of defamation that can mean
loss of income it could mean actual loss
of business as a result of the
defamation and then there's
general damages these are things that
are harder to put an actual monetary
price tag on things like
emotional damages pain and suffering or
loss of consortium
ask your parents about that one and then
there's punitive damages things that
aren't really
related to the injury suffered itself
but are meant to actually punish the
defendant
things that are meant to prevent them
from doing things again and then finally
let's talk about some of the defenses
that you can raise to a claim of
defamation obviously you can
show that the statement that you made
was true or substantially true and that
will generally defeat a claim for
defamation you can also show that the
statement at issue is one of opinion
rather than one of fact so with that
background let's
analyze some of the claims here
defamation is a
highly fact specific claim to make but
here we can probably make some
generalizations first of all the
claimed communications here seem to be
factual in nature they accuse mr coomer
of
actually doctoring voting machines that
doesn't seem like an issue of
opinion or of hyperbole that seems like
a verifiable fact that
could or could not be true it seems like
it's false
while it's highly contentious on social
media the reality seems to be that these
election related claims are
almost all made up and with respect to
the infiltrated antifa phone call that
seems to be
pure imagination sometimes you can raise
the defense that the communications
don't actually
involve the person claiming the
defamation but
here the social media posts and the
actual news reports
mention dr coomer by name here so uh
it seems like these communications are
about him specifically and of course
until these
news reports and social media posts ran
dr coomer was not
a household name and it would be very
difficult to prove that he was a public
figure and thus
he may benefit from the lower standard
not the actual malice standard but
simply the negligence standard because
he could prove that he is a private
person rather than a public figure
so the eric coomer defamation lawsuit is
the main one that's been filed so far
but it looks like
others are on the horizon from both
dominion and smartmatic now smartmatic
and dominion have
started filing suit but it doesn't look
like they've sued everyone that they've
threatened
yet but it's probably only a matter of
time until all of these clowns receive a
summons eventually and part of the
reason that they might not have filed so
far is that
many states have laws requiring a
plaintiff to first request a retraction
before they can recover certain types of
damages
in a defamation lawsuit and both
dominion and smartmatic
are basically scorching the earth with
their cease and desist letters
and making certain news organizations
bend over backwards to try and limit the
damages that
they might suffer in terms of a
defamation lawsuit and generally if you
want to know
how strong your defamation claim is you
can tell based on how quickly the
potential defendants roll over and give
you a retraction
and it's these kinds of demands for
retractions that can lead to hilarious
results like even newsmax muzzling mike
lindell
and an anchor walking away from him
after he started talking about some of
these
unverified accusations can i ask our
producers can we
get out of here please you know that
when even newsmax is afraid to touch you
number one you're a complete whack job
and number two
the retraction letter is doing its work
and retraction law is a really
interesting wrinkle
in the sort of defamation lawsuit area
generally states that have retraction
laws require a plaintiff to
request a retraction or notify the
defendant of the allegedly defamatory
statement
before they can file a lawsuit the
request or notice must be made within a
reasonable period of time after
publication
of the allegedly defamatory statement
and if the defendant responds by airing
a
frank and full retraction of the
defamatory statement the defendant will
be entitled to a reduction in certain
types of damages
in a majority of states retraction
prevents a plaintiff from recovering
punitive damages unless a plaintiff can
prove
malice in those states even if the
plaintiff proves malice a timely
retraction can mitigate
most of the punitive damages and some
states put the onus on the plaintiff to
be able to recover certain damages and
some states put the onus
on the defendants to be able to limit
their damages so for example
in california you have to send a letter
or else you'll only get economic damages
but in new york
if the defendant prints or airs the
retraction then the defendant can limit
the damages to economic damages only so
a retraction doesn't end the plaintiff's
lawsuit but it just
reduces the amount and type of damages
that are available to the plaintiff so
here
dominion and smartmatic have sent
letters to several people
and organizations which made false
claims about the 2020 election
smartmatic and dominion have demanded
that the media organizations retract
their false claims so let's look at some
of these retraction letters the first is
the smartmatic versus fox and newsmax
smartmatic's letter to fox news accused
the network of repeatedly airing false
and defamatory statements about the
company smartmatic said in the letter
that fox news had aided quote
a concerted disinformation campaign
presenting unsupported claims that the
company conspired to change the results
of the vote to benefit joe biden
although
most of the statements were made
originally by rudy giuliani and sydney
powell the allegations were repeated by
fox hosts like lou dobbs jeanine pirro
and maria bartoromo but the funny thing
is
smartmatic did not provide any services
to swing states nor did it tabulate
votes outside of los angeles but fox
news said smartmatic was literally
designed to change votes without
detection
and then send them out of the country
for tabulation and
newsmax and oann had pushed the voting
company conspiracies even harder than
fox news
we should make up stories because
they'll be far more interesting fellas
are you sure all of this is
ethical newsmax claimed that smartmatic
had relationships with all of the
right-wing scariest monsters the
clintons the pelosi family
george soros and hugo chavez yet after
they received the legal letter they
aired a detailed retraction here's a
newsmax host reading the script like a
hostage
newsmax has no evidence to the contrary
dominion has stated the company has no
ownership relationship with the pelosi
family the feinstein family
the clinton family hugo chavez or the
government of venezuela
newsmax also posted an article on the
website you can check out the scope of
the admissions here so these retractions
may
in fact reduce the damages that the news
organizations
face though the court does require that
a retraction be made in the same manner
as the original defamatory statement so
it's not clear that it's getting quite
the same sort of coverage that the
original allegations received which
was basically non-stop on these channels
for days if not weeks
of course if the news organizations
repeat the
false allegations it might undo the
retraction and a claim for defamation
might have
no limits in terms of the damages that
they can seek and now let's turn to the
potential case of smartmatic and
dominion versus
oan because the oan network has its own
interesting relationship with defamation
claims we should make up a bunch of
reports about how dangerous it is to be
alive
oh boy for one youtube suspended the oan
network for posting false information
about kobit 19 but on top of that
oen knows its way around a defamation
suit at least it knows what it's like to
be on the losing side of a defamation
claim
oyen actually sued rachel maddow last
year for defamation claiming that she
called the network paid russian
propaganda which
i guess maddow actually did apparently
an oan contributor was moonlighting as a
writer for sputnik the kremlin's
newspaper the lawsuit was dismissed
because the statement was maddow's
opinion
but here predictably oan has doubled
down on its groundless election fraud
claims the company responded to the
spartmatic and dominion letters which
demanded that
oan preserve all documents related to
the defamatory statements or potentially
defamatory statements which is a pretty
standard litigation tactic
by demanding that smartmatic and
dominion preserve all documents related
to
george soros which is interesting and
some
including the new york times have
speculated that if this defamation suit
were successful
it might be enough to shut down oan and
then there's the potential case of
dominion versus
sydney powell in some sydney powell
talked about dominion's connections or
purported connections with nicholas
maduro
the company's use of algorithms to flip
votes the founders saying his machines
can change a million votes for biden
its relationship with smartmatic its
relationship with george soros its
relationship with hugo chavez
kickbacks it paid to the state of
georgia its interference
in the hillary clinton 2016 primary win
and training election workers all over
the country to flip for biden
all of these allegations are
demonstrably false
says dominion and most rational people
and
powell has stated them as if they were
true she wrote about all these things
in blog posts went on tv and radio and
repeated them appeared at rallies and
made false statements in court and to
further amplify her lies she tagged
donald trump on twitter ensuring that
her claims
would be heard around the world now
after sending sydney powell a cease and
desist letter for the ages
dominion eventually did file suit
against her and dominion sought
1.3 billion dollars in damages but more
on that later
dominion is proceeding as if it will be
treated as a public figure
therefore the complaint pleads that
powell acted with actual malice
as evidence of malice the company
accuses her of lying about every facet
of the voting process dominion claims
this is defamation per se
because powell described dominion as the
perpetrator of quote the greatest crime
this century if not the life of the
world her comments inspired others to
say that dominion committed quote the
greatest crime in the history of the
country
but as we've talked about the difficulty
for dominion is proving that she acted
with
actual malice because to do so they have
to prove that she knew
that what she was doing was wrong rather
than just was acting crazy or using
hyperbole and the company's strategy
here is to argue that she's in the game
for the money that's
why the emphasis that she fundraised off
the effort that she seems to have a
501c4 group to get the money and that
she
ignores all of the evidence disproving
her claims because
as for hyperbole if powell actually
confined her comments to things like
this was the biggest heist in the
history of the world she'd probably have
a good argument
that it was clearly meant as an
exaggeration or even opinion but
powell's problem here is that she spouts
statistics
and things that feel like facts and her
comments even found their way into
president trump's phone call with brad
raffensberger which
i covered in a video a few weeks back he
claimed that the votes were shredded and
flipped
and massive numbers of dead people voted
and that dominion
took out the innards of the machines and
replaced them with i don't know a frozen
yogurt machine or something but
powell makes these same claims despite
the fact that they've been
completely disproven and not
surprisingly dominion says that
all of this naturally severely damaged
the company's reputation and
undermined its business the company
would likely have solid proof that
powell's claims have damaged its
reputation and almost certainly have
correspondence from
existing clients or prospective clients
saying that
they won't continue to do business with
dominion because of all of these crazy
allegations
certainly it seems clear that the fury
over these claims have created serious
pressure on local elections officials to
cut ties with dominion entirely
so for these reasons dominion seeks
punitive damages under both dc and
georgia law because they claim that the
statements
show willful misconduct malice
wantedness and conscious indifference
to the facts and speaking of illegal
action it's criminal how few people are
actually subscribed to this channel i
was looking through my analytics and
only a small percentage of viewers are
actually subscribed
so if you find this video interesting or
informative hit that subscribe button
and just when you thought
all the fun was over smartmatic dropped
a complete bomb a lawsuit seeking 2.7
billion dollars against
fox fox news lou dobbs maria bartoromo
janine pirro rudy giuliani and sydney
powell i covered this very briefly
before
but this is a somewhat unusual complaint
and it's very very clear that the
lawyers for smartmatic know that this is
as much a pr
play as it is actual litigation and the
intro to this particular complaint the
document that starts the litigation is
pretty epic it starts with one paragraph
the earth is round two plus two equals
four joe biden kamala harris won the
2020 election for president and vice
president of the united states the
election was not stolen rigged or fixed
these are facts they are demonstrable
and irrefutable and then the lawsuit
goes into paragraph number two
defendants have always known these facts
they knew joe biden and kamala harris
won the 2020 u.s election they knew the
election was not stolen they knew the
election was not rigged or fixed they
knew these truths just as they knew the
earth is round and two plus two equals
four
and then the complaint goes on in
paragraphs twelve and thirteen with this
action smartmatic says enough
facts matter truth matters defendants
engage in a conspiracy to spread
disinformation about smartmatic they
lied
and they did so knowingly and
intentionally smartmatic seeks to hold
them accountable for those lies and for
the damage that their lies have caused
smartmatic brings
16 claims against defendants for
defamation and disparagement spermatic
seeks to recover in excess of 2.7
billion for the economic
and non-economic damage caused by
defendants disinformation campaign as
well as punitive damages
finally smartmatic seeks a declaration
requiring defense to fully and
completely retract their false
statements and implications
so a couple of things about this
smartmatic complaint first is that
dominion filed a suit for 1.3 billion
smartmatic file a suit for 2.7 billion
dollars
and those are very very big numbers and
if these allegations are true
they probably suffered a great deal of
damages but the thing about these
particular complaints in any complaint
for that matter is that these numbers
are
completely fanciful you can basically
put any number you want in these
complaints
so just because they put these billions
of dollars in damages into the thing
that they're asking for the court
it has no bearing on the reality it
might be true but most likely it's
an inflated number designed to attract
attention and obviously these numbers
attract attention and it's impossible
not to recognize that sometimes
litigation is
as much about pr as it is about actually
getting the damages that you're owed
now the second thing is that these suits
are probably stronger than your average
defamation suit
in the smartmatic complaint there are
over 250 pages of allegations
it's clear that these lawyers have done
their homework and they're loaded for
bear and they talk a lot about the same
statements and allegations that we've
already covered in this video now in
performative defamation suits that
really don't have any basis in law or
fact like for example what devin nunes
tends to do
you get very broad allegations where the
lawyers characterize the statements
but don't actually say what the
statements are because the claims are bs
but here the lawyers painstakingly put
every statement
front and center verbatim into the
complaint which lends credence to the
idea that these lawyers actually believe
that the statements they are making
accusations about
are potentially defamatory now the third
thing is that these complaints would
probably withstand a motion to dismiss
if you've watched this channel you
probably know that emotion to dismiss
is taking all the accusations plaintiff
alleges as true it assumes them to be
true
just testing whether it would be legally
sufficient if it was true
and if you get past the motion to
dismiss that means you're into discovery
where you get to ask questions and
demand documents from the other side
and when you're in that universe that
can be really really bad
for the defendants because broad
categories of things that you don't want
disclosed
probably are disclosable in discovery
and then finally the fourth thing
is that at least in the smartmatic suit
there are 16 causes of action which
normally would give me pause because you
often will just
generate causes of action and claims uh
to try and throw everything against the
wall and see what sticks
but here all of the causes of action are
for defamation or disparagement of false
statements
because they're just talking about
different categories of topics of
statements that were made so it's not
like they're claiming 16 different
laws were broken but rather mainly two
sets of laws were broken it's just
there are different categories of
statements that fall into those
different buckets so the fact there are
16
claims doesn't really give me as much
pause as it would in a different context
and then finally smartmatic is seeking
punitive damages amongst other kinds of
damages which is interesting because
punitive damages are hard to get you
have to show particularly odious
and willful conduct to get punitive
damages because those damages are meant
to punish the defendant to make sure
they don't do it again
regular damages are just to compensate
the victim and
if smartmatic is successful improving
its claims punitive damages might not be
outside the realm of possibility so this
suit is by no means a slam dunk it's
probably
stronger than average when it comes to
political defamation suits
but if it were me i would not want to be
fox news or any of the fox news hosts
who have been sued as a result of these
claims
but if you published some of this
election nonsense and dominion sues you
then you'll need to call a good lawyer
i'm afraid these guys
might not be lawyers for very much
longer and the best way to make those
phone calls is with ting mobile
i personally switched to tingmobile why
because of this
yes this is a real bill that i got
but ting mobile has three brand new
plans to make sure that that will never
happen again you can get talk and text
for just ten dollars a month and pay for
the data you use get five gigabytes for
25
a month and even unlimited for just 45
dollars per month
switching plans is actually really easy
because you can keep your same phone
number and use pretty much
any phone and the service is great too
because ting partners with several
massive networks very possibly
the exact same network that you're using
right now but
at a huge discount now contractually i
can't tell you which ones they contract
with because
i always respect contracts but i've
noticed no difference
in my service since i switched so
whether you use
2 gigabytes or 20 gigabytes a month
there is a perfect team plan for you
and your family and if you don't use
that much data and you're around wi-fi
all the time which most of us are
considering we're probably working from
home
you still have the flexibility of ting's
original plan which can literally save
you
hundreds of dollars literally hundreds
of dollars
because ting's flex plan gives you the
option to pay for just what you use it's
a smarter cheaper version of the same
plan that they've always had
and now they're just adding unlimited
versions as well which are still way
cheaper than everybody else
so if you want unlimited data go crazy
so if you'd like to try out ting mobile
go to legaleagle.ting.com and you can
use your last build to compare just how
much you would save and
legal eagles will also get a 25 service
credit that could cover
literally months of service so just
click on the link in the description or
go to legaleagle.ting.com to save
hundreds of dollars on your cell phone
plan plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel but do you
agree with my analysis leave your
objections in the comments and check out
this playlist over here with all of my
other real law reviews where i talk
about
all the crazy things that happened with
the election and the trump
administration
so click on this playlist and i'll see
you in court